thank you so much for tuning in to
GameSpot after dark on YouTube this week
we talked about III getting cancelled
and some Nintendo games we'd love to see
get made if you want to skip ahead for
any reason I've left timestamps below
and with that thank you so much for
watching
hello and welcome to episode 32 of
GameSpot
after dark GameSpot's unofficial
official video game podcast joining me
this week is Callie plaguey
tomorrow who's saying hi ye and for the
last time Peter Brown goodbye
oh no you hate to see it yeah thank you
bye we've said you hate to see it today
you so many and the effect is
compounding so each time it adds to the
previous exponential here yeah like the
the hate to see it level it's just it's
just this is also the second time I've
said it's the last time we'll see you on
this podcast but people won't see the
first time recording this again yeah we
had some technical hiccups but yeah it
is your last week a spot yeah I'm going
to new gig I'm going to be in the gaming
industry um and I'm super excited about
it it's one of those things where it's
like when it was offered it was like oh
yes you know but like that yes was sort
of also like met with but wait but that
means I don't get to work with you know
my best friends anymore and that's
really what GameSpot has become for me
is my family you know my best friends
I'm I've changed so much the site has
changed a lot the industry has changed a
lot and it's been a very fun interesting
ride yeah you've been here eight years
nine years almost done almost nine if
I'm exaggerating if I'm doing that kid
thing of saying I'm four and a half
years old so ten years then I made it
yeah eight and a half years I guess is
probably the best way to look at it so
back before you know I was reviewing
like Wow 3ds has been around the entire
time almost but the ps4 was not I mean I
was here for the launch of the current
generation of consoles basically so a
couple years before that was looking at
ps3 games and
stuffin anyway yeah it's been a long
time ray a long time a quarter of my
life yeah that's that's one way to think
about it huh certainly that's a really
long time for this industry to like you
you've been doing this so long and I
think everybody here has a lot of
respect for your knowledge and for how
much that experience brings I think
we're gonna really miss that yeah I'm
sorry for being so assertive all the
time and making you think that I'm smart
[Laughter]
the fact that that smarts is couched in
like goofiness is like the best part of
it it's like it makes a the smart
moments which are frequent feel even
more like profound yeah it's like on
cooking shows when they're like the
sweetness is is just tempered by a hint
of acidity like it's just like I'm
caramelized onions yes we all strive to
be I can't talk drunk eating Wheat Thins
the other day and I was like they're the
perfect combination of salty sweet I'm
with dense drinking a wheat beer but I'm
not fence yeah I think in our first
attempt at this I said it and I'll say
again just so people know there's like
errors that define gamespot like dig
through my my period I was you know like
the Brian McDonald era then there was
like the Jeff Gerstmann era the Greg
Kasavin era and I definitely feel like
being part of the Peter Brown era has
been like a weirdly special moment for
me it's like growing up watching and
reading and doing all this stuff and
then also being kind of like a fan of
everyone here and then working alongside
us been it's been good I can only say
thank you because I don't know who this
person you're talking about is I credit
for how far I've come at games but I
would not I would absolutely not be
where I am I can't spot without Peter
Brown contrib sense isn't fair
yeah we meet it though it's not just the
beers we've been drinking since the
first take no not at all
not since the three o'clock notice that
we can't come to the office on Friday
I'm leaving a wild wild few days yeah
the gaming industry is like anemic right
now although it's not because there's a
ton of games coming out right now but it
feels like like I know I'm not that
self-centered but it feels like after I
gave notice the everything around me has
just been like it's it's really surreal
to be leaving now and to think that like
last week is my next week but we might
not be here yeah at all and it kind of
sucks but I'm enthused that I'm not
leaving the Bay Area that the place I'm
going has an office just down the road
so I might be able to be here once in a
while and still have lunch with you guys
so I don't I'm not so sad about its it's
weird I don't know I guess I'm not sad
as much as I am hopeful that the
friendships that exist now can persist
right like after I leave and stuff
because I know so much of gamespot like
a lot of jobs busting your ass and then
letting loose and there's just that's
been that's defined my time here and you
get to know people on levels like you
wouldn't because you see them at their
best and at their worst and you sort of
learn to trust each other in both of
those moments and and um I know I
certainly need a lot of that runway to
you know to get my stuff done like I rub
a lot of people certain ways like ship
this incredible use of content and then
like head in your hands like I can't
play this game anymore I can't people
who like read and consume out the stuff
that we make don't understand like how
personal it is that creation process
everything from a news story like to a
review to a major feature to a video
it's like deeply deeply personal and to
fact that the fact that you have this
group of people that you trust here look
at it and then tell you whether it's
good and help you make it good or tell
you it's bad and tell you
shouldn't be there right it's like
incredibly it is like very very personal
and you are baring your souls alike the
reason I mentioned that is because
having a group of people who you are
willing to do that wave it's is rare and
it's like feeling big it's that same
kind of like trust you put in family and
like you know yeah I mean I I credit
every single thing that I've learned or
gained here to the people I've worked
with who gave me that knowledge and to
begin with like I didn't come in here
like just waiting to to blossom you know
like I was watered it's it's everyone
here is has given me something and it's
it's just been a real privilege the
whole time and in a way I think you know
my exit is a really good opportunity for
things to evolve here not that I think
I'm holding anyone back but I don't know
like change is good right like change
can have a positive side to it so yeah I
we're still gonna be friends we're still
gonna hang out I'll still be on twitter
twitter twitter i'm still be talking
about CRTs I'm still gonna play new
video games and maybe once in a while
say something and most important yeah
thank you
anyone who's ever said anything nice to
me or not and thank you all right have
friends back home who who regularly
messaged me
oh not regularly whenever you appear on
a podcast I like that dude is so small
there's one particular guys named FAA
was your mom but no games but like every
time you are on a podcast talking about
like old games you message means like
that dude he's unbelievably smart like
you know just cuz I obsess over that
he likes everyone it I'd like the reason
I mentioned that is because like
everyone you know that fact that that
thing that you said that you know we'll
still be friends and that kind of
because I think that's what we're all
trying to tell ourselves right now and
it speaks to how difficult this is to
process like trying to reflect or making
sure that you're aware of fact that that
friendship is gonna endure and it's not
gonna be that adult thing where you know
yeah cool we could we were coworkers and
then they move to another job and forgot
forgot about that
that can't happen here yeah yeah I don't
think it's possible
and obviously I'm gonna make new friends
where I go right and go through the same
sort yeah I don't know who they are but
they so we try to get me to say here I
mean started no yeah but seriously it's
a they have a lot to live up to oh but
it that way I honestly I moved to this
country in part like I have several
factors I moved here I get to work with
some of the people I like the most Jake
cally you know of everyone else out here
like and if you were like you know
alright layer by I would be well upset
I'll be like I played I really thought
you're gonna be like some of the people
I like the most look at us and everyone
I love dearly
we love you Peter oh yeah yeah we're
gonna miss you you've been amazing
and I'm sure the thing that you're going
on to do will be better off to have you
I have it I'll [ __ ] it up if you just
come back you back in the real deal dad
yeah I am the real deal dad and y'all
are dogs for certain so this episode is
going to be a little different than
normal we're gonna breeze over this what
we've been playing section like I'm
thinking like say what you're doing give
one sentence
partially because of lots embargo
partially because it's crazy busy and we
want to yeah cancel is popping off my
friends and the other thing that I do
need to mention is that we probably
won't be here next week recording we're
still gonna have an episode but we won't
be sitting here because the coronavirus
has gotten almost out of hand in San
Francisco it seems like it's certainly
headed that direction escalating yeah
it's escalating so a lot of people are
gonna be working from home we're still
gonna try to make this podcast happen
but it will be I don't know a little
leaner than normal I would say but
anyway Peter do you wanna start give us
give us what you've been playing doing
on sentence that's it I'm playing
real-life Tetris because in addition to
getting a new job I'm also moving to a
new apartment love it it's more planned
born all right again that's it I'm
playing Animal Crossing that's all I can
say I'm playing call of duty war zone
which is something else but we do have
one big news story yeah the reason why
we wanted to cut down the conversation
on what we've been playing is because we
imagine the fact that III has been
cancelled this year due to the corona
virus might dominate this episode quite
a bit mm-hmm I've got nothing to lose
Jake I've got a conspiracy theory yeah
all right let's hear you Oh everyone had
bad things to say about e3 like oh man
why don't they just cancel I don't want
to be there all these companies are
pulling out they leaked all that info
they lead all that info that weird
activation stuff and here we are now and
it's like everyone's criticizing our
show oh there's a reason we might want
to cancel it well fire me GameSpot you
can't I can't accuse the ESA but isn't
it convenient it is very glad they're
taking the precaution because I think we
should be over cautious right now but
still well did you see the coronavirus
convention got cancelled because of the
corona virus I'm serious an actual
headline on not the onion I don't
what it was what a measly Union I don't
think it was news and feathering maybe
was a funny was it the post I don't know
maybe it is made up but I I saw a tweet
and I thought it was very funny and I
should Callie what coronavirus has been
around for a long time it sound like a
new thing yeah just the strain of that
is caught yes that's one of the the
weird things not to be like I'm not a
doctor but like coronavirus is a
classification of viruses yeah and so
that's why you seek Ovid 19 being this
specific strain and the 27th strain the
note novel coronavirus yeah meaning like
just the new strain there's another
there's another name for the the actual
disease you contract but it's basically
like pneumonia in both your lungs sick
it's like it's like lower bald ammonia
is a lower respiratory yeah thing we're
all doctors here not a doctor doctor
spot doctor brown spot my screen name on
gamespot his Doc Brown so I wouldn't lie
I'm a doctor
not report this was weird news to me
because III is both very stressful and
very fun I feel like my first III in the
games industry was like I still had
enough energy where I was like out every
single night and like doing stuff and
talking to people and like does that
mean going to the fig I was going to the
fig every night yeah
one time I went to Denny's one night I
went to Denny's I guess and this passed
III I was like I'm really sleepy mm-hmm
and I'm exhausted and I'm gonna go to
bed and I
I don't know if that's just me or if a
lot of people have been feeling that way
of like oh it used to be like work hard
party harder at e3 and then like lately
it was just like work hard watch like
Family Guy reruns in your hotel room
because there's nothing else to watch I
think I think the work hard part of it
became more elaborate and and like way
more you'd think like oh yeah back in
the day when you know video streaming
was nascent it would be really difficult
and yeah it probably was but these days
the productions are so elaborate
unlike the energy required to do it is
so much that I think even if you're
doing the same amount of work and
partying as before like the work part of
it really hits you hard like I was the
same like I'm I'm boring in that I don't
like partying anyway but like I remember
my first you feels like how did people
how are people going out I was exhausted
and everyone's like yeah let's go and
hang out and murder Ali Ali so that's
the difference we had murder Ali murder
Ali being the parking lot hanging out
zone behind the was it Mary I see the
USC Radisson oh my god that yeah I mean
we just have in our backyard a party
zone tables chairs well lit at night
cats you could just feed barbecue and
laugh at it as a group bring lots of we
would bring lots of Tecate and then
eventually people would get mad at us
for being out there too late the cops
showed up a couple times I lost a shirt
out there for sure that I still upset
about I never got to experience murder
alley during my time at GameSpot and it
really bums me out I last murder Ali was
right before a joint oh I saw it once
and my pervading memory is Jason
Ostreicher from John Baum first time
I've ever smoked him just our right
challenge went to a street fight I match
in his hotel room and I was like I kind
of want to play Street fire by the same
time I don't really know I know you but
I don't really know you I I'm just gonna
say no just in case either I'm going in
there and he's whooping my ass
or like it's just gonna get weird well
it's like well I'm just like oh I'm
actually into someone else's hotel room
I don't know who they are but now I've
seen Walker and I'm like
should have done it yeah I don't know
like I really can't tell if it's I'm
older and more tired or if it's the
nature of III changes the nature of the
work changes maybe it's a combination of
everything but things have gotten way
more intense on the average day in this
industry if that's one thing I can talk
about it's it's the evolution of it's
like what you're saying for you three
but really it is every day here like the
idea that the video is obviously so
important the idea that one person has
to be able to do all these different
things
I mean it's necessary now for sure yeah
the amount that we do in a day even from
a variety range
yeah the variety like today I cut a
script edited a review shot a video
during a podcast I'm doing a podcast
like that's a lot to do in one day and
that is not like like yes it is a busy
day but that's not like it's an average
day now get that leading all the way up
to e3 or you're supposed to sleep in
hotels
yeah interface with people on like ten
times the amount of normal it's it's
great and it's not yes to be clear we're
not moaning about this because like I
remember being I've heard this
conversation before and I remember being
on the other side being like damn I wish
I could do that so to that person who's
there and what is like me being like I
learned some of the component about
we're not complaining yeah it's just
very intense and draining we loved every
moment of it it's just a lot it is a lot
and like at e3 last year like a lot of
us hosted things on top of doing like
for us editorial work video editing
production like we're also getting in
front of the camera and that is a whole
other state of mind it's a whole there
kind of energy like it is like when
you're combining types of work like that
you're switching it's like yeah it's
hard to get into like a rhythm yeah and
it's it's cool it's it's it's awesome to
feel that accomplished like to e3s ago
when I got to interview oh my god
behinds Pete Hines I was gonna say I was
like not feel spencer why is my brain
dude I know I'm literally talking about
a highlight I can't remember Pete Hines
name right now anyway I wilt so
accomplished I was really proud of that
interview and then I went and I turned
that interview in a news stories like
right after I shot it and I was like wow
that was like such a cool thing that I
did combining skills that I have like
III gives you that opportunity unlike
any other show at least in America um
obviously because Gamescom is very large
but uh and smelly yes it's Gamescom but
loser shut it's like I'm disappointed
because I won't have that but I'm also
like kind of relieved because I'm
already tired and March yeah I am I'm
bummed for sure 33 is definitely my
favorite part of the year it used to be
always like as a kid and stuff like that
was because of the games now I mean
still the games are obvious
but always like having the other
international offices come seeing other
people in the industry interesting
everyone like it's so excited about news
announcements and all that kind of stuff
is always just so much fun I will say
one thing that took the they kind of
took the sting out of the announcement
though was last year when they leaked a
bunch of contact information for people
who went and I think at that moment I
was just like I was like I don't I don't
know if I feel comfortable coming to
this to the show registering for this
show if they don't take privacy that
seriously and then it happened again and
then having yes company I do want to say
which probably phrase it like the
information was not secure and it was
leaked rather than they leaked it yes
correct you it's just for like for
covering our base it was essentially
like if you had a link you could access
all those very information we were very
fortunate in that but a lot of people we
know we're not and that is definitely a
concern because we were exhibitors it's
not media that was a difference I think
the general sentiment for people like
especially that work here is like we
love d3 as Pam would say you know the
vibes they all fun it was like a great
time to come together and you know
celebrate gaming get excited about see
friends that are you know from other
parts of the same company or the company
the planets the planets see virtual
friends like Mario Miku and Gears of War
chunky man and DJ fun bags at the same
time yo guitar oh yeah
nori tomorrow III has been through like
weird swings in the past like there was
one time where it was held in Atlanta in
the 90s oh yeah you know there was one
time where was held in like an airplane
hangar in Santa Monica I want to say so
it's this isn't the first time the
show's been disrupted it's gonna come
back it's too big to not exist the
industry we're all here yeah we complain
about little bit we ultimately love it
the industry also needs
in a way there is no other event that
brings everyone together with that like
GDC is close to it that industry
mentality but that's it's not quite the
same it's not the same stage right
and you I've seen a lot of tweets from
people talking about like this is hard
on smaller developers because a lot of
people rely on those face-to-face
contacts to get word out about their
game or to just make a friend an ally in
the industry convince a drunk person to
give you money yeah or if you were like
me going to III 2013 I don't even know
how I got in to be honest with you I
didn't work in the industry yet I was
still in college and I like I remember
running into someone from IGN cuz I did
some freelance by that time or I had
been in the office by that time for
something and he was like what are you
doing here and I was like what are you
doing here being very I feel like that
that helped me somehow and I got very
lucky in that way
I obviously there's a lot that can be
done remotely mm-hmm in our line of work
but there are some things that are hard
to replace with face-to-face human
contact yeah it's an event a lot comes
out of it and this year we don't get to
experience that yeah well that is one
thing that I imagine we're still gonna
see right is press conferences big
announcements it'll just be I imagine on
a different timeline because I can't
imagine you know Microsoft's probably
already planning something they've been
planning something I imagine like maybe
they won't have the same stage maybe
they'll choose a different date but I
imagine there's gonna be a day where do
they do the XO well they've said they're
digital
they're doing oh they're doing some
looking at their options Nintendo I mean
like Nintendo does right is weird
because at the same time as are saying
like oh it will come back well also like
we've never been as equipped in terms of
technology and the audience being primed
for an entirely digital show you know
like between Nintendo directs and
streaming and that kind of stuff all the
platforms it could vary
I hope it does come back but it could
very easily know
come back I mean let's imagine in III
right without like executives on stage
and fake people in the audience
screaming at their mundane BS that's
where the fun is
that's well the twisted twisted fun yeah
yeah you need you need house jacket you
get so many amazing moments yeah yeah
mister caffeine I should Tyler who've
got poop god oh god can we talk about
how Reggie also works now for Game Stop
one hundred forty thousand dollars a
year just to give them a device I hope
his advice is always that you know that
giving ways like excuse me while I play
Anna what is this like I can't talk
right now
I have to go play animal crossing on my
Nintendo 3ds those are closing I can't
talk right now that's probably not the
exact Reggie unlucky three yeah but
before we do move on from e3 I just want
to like go around the room favorite e3
memories announcements whatever it might
be there's a few that come to mind for
me I think the I'd love to see how much
just spit that guy who is on the flute
generate at the place let's go be
buckets just think of Luke I just go in
absolutely ham on that flute
just a mouse saliva it must have been
generated there what's yours I mean a
couple the first thing that comes to
mind though is I remember when they
announced the Final Fantasy 7 remake was
it was my first e3 and like the war room
just went absolutely nuts no enemy I
know but like I didn't really care cuz
like I never played the first one I
wasn't waiting for this like so many
other people but it was just hard not to
catch that energy just because people
were yelling and screaming and and
freaking out and now here we are five
years later in the game is about to come
out Dan
Kelly um this was oh gosh what was it
called it was when Nintendo hosted like
those competitions that they played live
and I was taking our world championships
yes and I remember being in the IGN war
room and watching the Super Mario maker
stuff and everyone was really into it
there was a lot of fun and I don't know
it was it was a very positive experience
just like everybody being really into
watching and like treating it like a
sport when I was like I understand
sports and um a lot of fun with that and
I guess
the fig if you can call those memories
right just give responsibly and I'll
drink to that
one time the IG on Australia
team was in a pre Airbnb uh on Skid Row
and a flophouse basically I think mine
like the shame is wildly problem acting
up I just remembered leaving the war
room and just stepping out and Kanye
West's dead-eyed looking at me like I
was like oh
Kanye West is here everyone was like
immediately the messages at the parents
like Kanye West is literally standing
outside and this was like I think off
the back of my Beautiful Dark Twisted
Fantasy
so it was like pre Kanye's like don't ya
like Jesus was the easiest got it had to
be Jesus maybe it was yeah it was still
pre like he's lost his mind cuz that was
like right before I sorry I'm just
really enjoying the Kanye discovery
it's sad but yeah it's like going really
quickly I forgot remember when all the
zombies were walking around what year
was that last year the year before this
is two years ago that was annoying so
there's all these but I went I went to
the women's restroom and I saw some like
zombie feet under the stall and I was
like yo what the [ __ ] do you what who's
on be fart smelling you know I was like
babe like Starbucks microwave sandwiches
yeah yeah you afraid to really get a
whiff in there oh yeah I was like that's
not I don't like that I don't like that
I could see your zombie feet stomp it
was like it was just me and her in there
too and it was a it was like a thirty
stall bathroom because there's no
anywhere in this industry in the
bathrooms there's only like two of us in
there at one time the one next to the
occupied one yeah yeah so Kanye West was
one and then probably the other one is
I think just doing interviews like I
like doing interviews a lot that's where
I'm going I really like talking to
developers I'll let you say it but like
I think we're aligned on this like well
especially the date the one day that I
remember if I'm not combining memories
by accident it was really early I think
I might have been my first c3 it was
like in the same day I was interviewing
a pretty mighty number 9 Keiji Inafune a
hideo kojima and also talking to David
Cox and Mercury steamed about
castlevania lords of Shadow so I was
talking to like new Castlevania game the
guy who I associated with Mega Man and
Theo Kojima and
I remember like going to that Kojima
interview with Kevin Bernard and feeling
like so out of my league but also like I
need to say something I need to ask
questions I need to not just sit here be
a loaf and even if Uday like it's crazy
how much he's fallen how far he's fallen
but at the time to me he was like an
icon and then yeah and then I don't know
lords of Shadow Castlevania is weird but
Castle many means a lot but that was
like all that one day like it just I
just I felt like that was what made that
III like that watershed moment for me
like I'm here watch over me you know
this is it yeah there's something about
this the simplicity of interviews I
really love it being amongst the chaos
of everything that happens in e3 it's
enlightening because it cut I
immediately lose that that false image
of who I think these people are yeah
even if they don't give you anything a
material value it's still like oh they
do occupy the same space idea they
breathe the same air they're just people
and if human eyes is like video games in
a way right I remember like I think this
was last year well was it the Todd
Howard interview we mean you did two
years ago two years ago yeah like I got
off the plane like I've landed got off
the plane and drove from the airport
straight to the Todd Howard interview
and if you go back and watch it like I'm
just like tripping and like I look I
messed the plane from London not in San
Francisco I think it was something silly
I was trying to make your story more
impact but it was like London to San
Francisco in San Francisco to LA so it
was like I was still jet-lagged yeah
sure yeah he meant you had to like cover
a Nintendo Direct or something yeah yeah
yeah and then like quickly grabbed Jake
we met up and then went into that
interview and I remember thinking thank
god this is an interview like because if
it was like be on stage and you know
talk about a game or like you know it's
something like that or pre or post show
I would have fallen asleep or pooped
myself or something being a host is
hosting those live segments very tough
if you're not interviewing someone you
don't like a couple like I don't think
I've been on longer than an hour and
it's it's so drain
hats off to everyone who does it in I
mean yeah even just like the process of
getting your makeup on before that is
draining and then the whole time I'm up
there I'm like thinking about like my
lipstick is definitely on my teeth
because I never wear lipstick and like
just like stupid things like that but it
all adds up reminded me of my actual
favorite III memory which is when I got
to meet Miyamoto I literally forgot
three ones and it was during the Star
Fox zero he was like a demo and they're
like oh Miyamoto is gonna come around
and ask everyone what they think I don't
know if you know Star Fox zero you guys
played that game if you have to use the
motion controls of the Wii U gamepad to
like steer your ship and I had to tell
me Emoto well I met Miyamoto on the day
that IGN gave breath of the wild the
game of show hmm and I was shadowing an
interview and I was like nodding along
to things and like filtrated turned to
me at the end of the interview and he
was like you know some Japanese don't ya
and I was like
I mean a little bit I don't consider
myself very good a Japanese and he was
like I saw you nodding along and I'm
like I don't mean to die I don't know
but I was so I was just like because the
part at the end of the interview was
like being like oh and by the way
Miyamoto son IGN has given birth in the
wild our game of show and I was just
like MIMO I must have been like I have
an embarrassing III story so I I saw it
was a couple years ago I saw blood
stains it was a 505 they usually in room
505 across from us so I walked in there
and I was setting up capture good job to
them forgetting room five and I was
sitting up and it wasn't working and I
was having some issues and I like stood
up to like change something and I pulled
out their PC with it I like caught the
wire pulled out the wire the thing fell
over and I never heard about this just
watching me and I'm like I'll put it all
back so I put it all back I don't get
the capture to work I just pretend it's
working or like it's fine you guys are
gonna send us biro right now like I
almost said you'd be wrong so then there
was that and I was incredibly
embarrassed and I was like I don't ever
want to have to cover that game again
hopefully I don't I don't have to see
gurashi again cuz that was terrifying
and then a couple years later cuz that
game was in development for awhile I
went to another blood-stained prison
like an xbox like like showcasing know
that game was there a while it was still
like it wasn't room 505 but it was still
nearby 502 B yeah it was like - you
store whatever and I walked in and I was
setting up capture knows like I can't do
anything stupid this time nothing stupid
and I was setting up capture and I went
down to plug it into a power strip and I
actually flip the power strip off in
like four units next to just shut down
as they were previewing and I was like
oh my god
so I was like luckily he wasn't there it
was just 505 PR actually also developed
the switch port for I am so sorry
and luckily it was right at the
beginning so it didn't really like
people didn't have to restart too much
but I was like yeah I'm never covering
that game again they're like good and
I've been like pretty good I have like I
think the two biggest fuck-ups I've had
covering e3 or covering anything in that
were those two games or that that game
twice and I'm just like cursed my one
was the almost [ __ ] my pants on stage
which is has been caught and the other
one was like a row of preview for a
first-person shooter which I won't name
and I was like this is just boring man
and then like remember being told it was
my first e3 and then member being told
if you're gonna you know slag off one of
the major first-person shooters in the
industry just give us a heads up so we
can prepare ourselves so no one wasn't
that wasn't anyone saying like don't do
it was just like yeah we got some we got
some like people talking to us about
this and it would have been good if we
if we knew it was coming I was like I
was I was proof right because later that
year again did not get great support I
think the three memory that I have
forgotten about maybe for good reason is
after a vigorous night in murder alley
year one loss issue the next day I was
incredibly hungover and going to
appointments and I think my third
appointment was for Dishonored
the first one well game and I'm still
just uneasy and someone else is playing
someone else from GameSpot and I'm
watching over their shoulder and because
it's like a first-person game it's like
fast-moving and they're controlling the
camera not me I just get this sense of
like okay I have to throw off oh my god
I want to throw up and so I said I have
to go I ran out to the bathroom there's
like you know an e3 bathroom there's
like 12 stalls this that you know all of
them fall I was like
Hey look at the urinals I was like no
I'm not gonna do that so I looked in the
mirror and I said you got this and I
like stood there and like steal the
vomit down and then I left and I was
like okay I'm already out of this
appointment I'm not expected to be in
the war room right away
it's like I'm gonna go out to the
production van and see what they're
doing and maybe I can take a nap
I watched the production man and I took
a nap for 90 minutes in the middle of
day two of you know I came back to the
war I'm like I'm in trouble no one said
a thing
no one knew now you know that's sick
pretty good it's better I survive I
think I've heard part of that story
there's more to it actually but I know
someone that took a nap during e3 while
I was here and everyone noticed because
that person was essential and I was like
you shouldn't be nothing to a player
well anyway there is a question that
someone wrote in about III so we'll get
back to a Borg and move on to listener
questions oh wait before we move on
right did you see the the identity of
who was controlling the hem do account
was revealed no yes tell me there's a
twitter account called hem to it which
is a food that is we get catered lunch
it's boxed lunches it's crap and there's
one of them it's known where it's known
for these lines and there's a Twitter
account about the of that ham do it
basically just in case I'm coming 20
days until the person who controls that
account revealed who they were today who
do you think it is so if I remember
correctly I want to say cuz they
initially it was like it's gotta be Sean
McKenna's or Chris waters or Giancarlo
very Nene or Tyler wine garner and I I
think Tyler wine Garner is where I'm
landing now okay but I assume about
Tyler I see you know do you know I think
I might know someone who is
is Eddie McCune I thought it was I
thought it was Eddie makuu being
longtime news ray along GameSpot yeah
currently working at the Australia
offers the idea was given to him as he
recounted today by Brendan Sinclair for
VG business and like former editor hair
but he's been maintaining that account
since Eddie McCool it was Eddie Mack
it's just you never expect that from him
well he's Eddie makuu's evolved over the
years yeah he's very like when you
message him he's very proper he responds
in full sentences from Connecticut he
knows what's up yeah but but Jake seem
seen the Australia drinking out of a
shoe Eddie so I don't know if I've seen
him do that what's the call of footy in
personality is like a different person
yeah like he's like and he left then he
came back and he was really cool clothes
I heard he was robbed Edmond tranning
the Hammond do account and for
maintaining a lot yeah if you go and
follow the how do you account like he
said like it might be time to close this
but you never know give us some love and
in mind just reappear yeah Karen sorry
to interrupt you what were you about to
say that that's our question I was gonna
say we're moving on to listener
questions the last question is about e3
so we'll get back to it and I think that
last question was sent in before e3 was
officially kindled same for more than
one though what time is it it's it's
already I think we're just gonna go five
six okay why don't we do why don't we do
the first and last one then cuz I think
the first one should be pretty quick
it's a long question but should be a
quick one because hopefully people just
rattle off ideas anyway I'll read it
hey all one of the best slash most
surprising things about the switch has
been in
pendo letting people have some fun with
their iconic franchises with cadence of
I rule being very well-received one
would hope they might try something like
that again
so what small indie developer would you
like to see get a chance to make to make
a Nintendo game personally I think the
dead cells team is full of wonderful
ideas and while having them make a
Metroid might be an obvious call I'd
really like to see them make a Kid
Icarus game that looks like the original
but with the fast and slick slick
movement that dead cells excels at I bet
you guys have some characters and
franchises on your own personal wish
list too
thanks for making this wonderful show
for us every week Nick from Iowa City
Nick so I had a couple I didn't think of
actually a developer I guess but I've
gone someone should make they should get
an indie developer to make some like
sick f-zero game because like it's it's
clear that Nintendo Tizen isn't super
interested in making an f-zero game
anytime soon but I think there are some
people that would put a lot of love
there any indie racing game devs I don't
know a lot of any racing games I've seen
are like they're trying to make the
arcade racer again the low-poly like you
know yeah high chroma like thing that
has a lower cost yeah threshold - um I'm
really not good at these questions there
is a reason I got into editing things
and it's because I'm not very good at
creating them so Tim what a jury's
Toby Fox makes a new mother game
oh that's obvious yeah yeah I think the
team that has most comprehensively
proved that they could take a Nintendo
franchise understand the spirit of it
and make something new is Yacht Club
games they've just been making NES games
so like the shovelknight team given
Wario give him a new marry a game and I
pay you they'd be amazing and given
waluigi give him what you give him that
Yacht Club games make a waluigi
platformer
toby fox making a mother game is also
tell the CEO
tell the CEO of gamestop that we need
your club games Reggie fils-aime a game
yeah I want Arc System Works to make
Capcom vs. SNK 3 oh my lord give them
everyone else's properties and see what
they can do that would be incredible
what do you think of that what would
that be wild I need to my he's no longer
there so he was I was holding out a
holster he was secretly making it yeah I
just don't know what about uh stardew
valley devs making like Animal Crossing
I was thinking about concerned ape doing
something but I I already have started
belly and I have Animal Crossing so it's
like I don't need mmm cuz stardew valley
is just uh oh my god that is Oh is there
anyone that you can think of that can
make any advance was well we had that
one last year tiny middle did you play
it no was it good it was it was pretty
good yeah like what you're looking for
it's got it bagel you know would be cool
this has nothing to do with Nintendo but
I would really love a spin-off game of
the Cabaret club minigames and the Yaak
is a game good idea that's a solid idea
I just want I want that on my switch I
just want to manage a cabaret Club
concerned ape could make that work
better I would just like Yasumi Matsuno
to make Final Fantasy Tactics 2 which
was actually in development and some
screenshots were showed off like two
years ago and he was like but that's
never happening okay so we move on to
the last question it's faded for some
reason do you wanna read a counter same
hello to the G sad crew first I want to
say that first I wanted to say that I
enjoy the hadouken episode I remember
when great work on the show there mister
cut Davina
mmm he was talking last week about a
British people call him cut second yeah
it appears I've stumbled upon another
fine podcast from GameSpot called you
should be watching it is also pretty
enjoyable so far now that the after-dark
podcast is big time
generous we're pretty weird middle time
each how about a plug for you should be
watching so that others can discover it
as well that is a great idea there is we
have it don't we that is it that was the
plug was we were gonna mention at the
end but there the plug
you should be watching from our universe
team and lastly speaking of III assuming
everyone on the show this week has
attended the event what is the one thing
you always wanted to do at e3 that you
never could do to the work schedule or
other circumstances keep up the great
work guys gray fox PS okay now you can
take a pee break alright you're kidding
I mean the first thing that comes to
mind is I've never been to a press
conference and I figured that would be a
big part of the job is like oh you're
covering e3 you got to go to all the
press conferences and you gotta like
take notes while you're there never been
to one I had the opportunity to go to a
Microsoft one but it just felt weird to
just like leave while everyone else is
working like really hard in the war room
okay well I'm gonna go to this Microsoft
press conference so I I haven't done
that that would be a cool thing to do
one of these days comes with mine I
I don't I really wish I could have met
owada um I was first I don't know what
it was but I was so consumed by sadness
when he passed away
um and I remember my first III thinking
like what if i streetpassed miyamoto
what if i streetpassed Reggie and that
was like such a goal of lying was to
Street pasts like big-time people which
is like such like a that sounds like
like antiquated sentence now but I was
like new leaf had just come out and I
was trying to get people's houses in my
happy home showcase and yeah so like
there's people who wanted me I guess
funny story based off that I did CEO uh
once and it was it's basically the thing
that you won't happen to happened to me
like I walked and I was opening my 3ds
to see who I'd got and it was there and
then I looked and I can see him in the
distance and I was like I mean that
could very well been just a different
Japanese man with the same statue in a
suit but like it was I was sure it was
damn I still have that radiance with him
and Miyamoto on it one III I got both of
them like I clearly walked past Miyamoto
and get a notice but I noticed someone
that looked like Mufasa yeah and Kurt
was in the bathroom with Jack Black
really jealous I can't be in the
bathroom with Jeff Jack Black so you
know he's an icon he actually sings
tribute while he pees which is really uh
yeah I guess mine is like there's just
people I wish I could meet which is
really like there is a very short list I
am not that kind of person to get
starstruck but um I don't do a lot of
interviews I would say I'm like pretty
green with interviews I guess green I
just I don't feel like I'm funny and
creative with interviews like you are
like you just you open the interview
with who do you think you are yes I have
lost that question in a roundabout way
too
in your eyes why do you matter yeah I
don't think I've I can't think of like
what I wish I had would want to do or
was able to do I think I did most of the
things that I can think of wanting to do
and it's like doing interview be on a
stage you know chatter it would be good
if I could eat from the food trucks you
know the right now maybe maybe like
consider catering to people who only eat
a certain kind of halal or kosher meat
so I'm that of course yes easy easy
that's right I wish I could have given
Cliff Bleszinski a wedgie down in front
I wish I could have had one more III
with all of you anyways there is Senate
that's it's the one man all right well
this has been episode 32 of GameSpot
after dark thank you so much for tuning
in we'll be back next week maybe not in
these exact seats but we'll be doing
something Kelly where can people find
you on Twitter oh wait hold on sorry
before I do that if you have any
questions for us make sure to email
after our podcast at gamespot.com
that way we can respond to them on the
show yeah you can find me on twitter at
in quito chica i nky DOJ I Kate Kate oh
please check out the competitive Pokemon
series that Jake and I worked very hard
on we're very proud of it I know it's
nice please give it a watch it would
mean the world to me I am sorry to be
begging but I really would love it if
you watch it's very good it's very also
check back Monday for things oh I mean
you never know what could happen on a
Monday over a weekend wild weekends are
wold you can find me actually don't find
me find at PC Brown and on Twitter and
tell him that you love him
tell him if you read or watch anything
he did and it you know
resonated with you if it touched you a
certain touched you if you want to be
watered by his PC Brown yeah but like
just charm some love because yeah that's
it you can find me on Tim's like feed on
Twitter at slash like don't do that
you'll find are we gonna hear your final
fantasy 7 impressions once are do you
plan on playing final fantasy 7 of
course because I want to hear what you
think of that don't bring up yeah that's
gonna be my game to review my heart I'm
gonna morning you told me you're
quitting Jake's like Peters gonna review
Final Fantasy 7 remake right I was like
I'll [ __ ] fight him if he doesn't and
then you were like I'm leaving yeah I
definitely am super curious about that
game the demo has made me more excited
and more concerned so yeah I want to
play more than ever and I'll say
something about it thanks everyone
cool bye Peter bye Joe
[Music]